marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hi everyone welcome to vaynerx presents
marketing for the now i'm andrea
sullivan cmo of vaynerx and i'm here
with gary vaynerchuk
gary we've got one question today do you
know what it is
how are you growing your consumers into
fans in 2021
let's go hashtag marketing for the now
first up we welcome neda whitney she is
the svp and head of marketing for
christie's
neda recently joined christie's and it
seems there is no
coincidence with neta's arrival and the
69 million dollar
nft sale of people's art prior to
christie's net has spent
two years or two decades sorry working
agency side
around the world most recently at rga as
the managing director
a fun fact neda thought politics was her
future and she served as a white house
intern
in under the clinton administration
welcome neda
thanks guys so excited to be here hey
gary
hey nana how are you i'm well i'm well
how are you doing
quite quite well uh thanks for being
here obviously exciting timing
uh given all the buzz in the last couple
of weeks uh before i get into the
question
uh for the show why don't you give the
audience um
maybe a one or two minute background on
who you are i like them to get to know
you
uh and for everybody in the audience uh
i'm extracting a lot from twitter in
today's episode first
big shout out to everybody on instagram
live i know the team is streaming it we
the software we use doesn't
automatically upload but the team's
holding
camera two screens so instagram welcome
everybody get on twitter hashtag
marketingforthenow
if you have a question there's the
conversation and there is neda's
twitter handle next to her name so to
that point
uh netta give me uh one to two minutes
on you and your career
yeah as andrew mentioned i have spent 20
years
on the agency side of things i'm working
in new york san francisco london and
paris and all different types of
agencies
started my career at inner brand in
brand design
and then spent some time in pr 360
multicultural
and in the past 10 years i would say i
really focused around
digital and 360 marketing so most
recently as was mentioned i was the svp
managing director of client services at
rga
where i ran a number of different
businesses um some really exciting stuff
i worked on planned parenthood
i worked on uber i worked on amazon and
spent the last year and a half working
on the verizon business there so a very
eclectic career background
a mixed bag of clients and never had i
worked in the art or auction space
until i got a call from the team at
christie's and
it was a call i couldn't refuse there's
so much
interesting stuff happening right now in
the art and auction world uh you guys
mentioned the people sale for 69 million
that is just the tip of the iceberg on
some of the innovations we are working
on here
at the firm and so it was a really
exciting time for me to dive in
to what we call in the agency world a
client-side opportunity
with a firm like christie's and
understand how i could help be a
proponent for digital innovation
new customers new clients i love your
question about how we're turning clients
into fans
so let's let's go let's go into that i
think you know there's a lot of
entrepreneurs who might have 10 clients
on here
and then they're c-suite executives who
have hundreds of thousands
from your perspective maybe in the macro
and then maybe in the micro of what
christie's is doing specifically
how do you think about that question how
do you think about
growing customers into actual fans
yeah i think you know christie's is a
200 plus year old
firm so we got a lot of legacy there and
a lot of our relationship or our
business is still based around
relationship building
it is core to what we do and it is that
one-to-one relationship building of
really
knowing our clients knowing the art and
artifacts they're interested in and how
do we meet that appetite
but as every single um person i'm sure
you're talking to out there is
acknowledging
there's always the need to grow the
lifeblood of your firm and for us that
means
new entrants into the art and auction
space and intersecting with those
passion points so
i think the nft art that we recently
sold has shown us that there is a
completely new sector
of folks out there that can really be
engaged in the types of uh
offerings that we have we had over 91
of the registrants for that sale were
new to christie's
so there's always the opportunity to
build that that client base and i think
for us
it's finding out what are the passions
we can truly service
whether that's with burgeoning spaces
like digital art
or today we announced the innovation in
our sales schedule
for our 20th and 21st century art so
we're going to be splitting those sales
to recognize the artwork done in the
20th century and then create a platform
for that done in the 21st where those
artists were dealing with
really different topics like the aids
crisis and race
and gender and now digital art so
see seeing those trends and how they ebb
and flow and how our clients are
interested in them and mimicking that
and being really stewards of the art
world in that way
helps our clients turn into fans how do
you think
um how do you define a fan versus a
client
in that sentence i think a fan is
someone who
wants to see what christie's is doing
next and what we're pinpointing
so in our industry it is a duopoly
and i think because we sell unique art
and artifacts
you're always going to want to buy the
thing that resonates with you there's no
way that we can procure the exact same
item as a sotheby's or another auction
house because they're one of a kind
which is a unique marketing challenge
right to tell those stories with with
great regularity and frequency
but i think turning our clients into
fans is making them want to hear the
stories that we tell and the
perspectives through which we tell them
so i think
you know with this 20 to 21 shift
creating a platform for new artists
that's something that only christie's is
doing really creating that platform and
allowing that art
to stand alone from some of the
masterpieces that we're also known for
in the 20th century i think with
acknowledging digital art and creating a
space for it
again that's something that christie's
did first and our clients can truly
become
fans of what we're going to recognize
next and open their eyes to
how do how do you think a small business
can use nfts
to their advantage during this time any
any thoughts on that given your great
background in agency land and business
land
just to take a step over here to bring
value to everybody is consuming
anything anything stand out you have a
hot take on that i mean it's so early
and so you know these are more
hypotheses than they are
you know realities just yet since it's
so early but anything stand out for you
if you have like a
if you're you have a best friend who's
got an smb
and they're like oh my god you just had
that big thing happen like how should i
be thinking about it with my coffee shop
or my direct-to-consumer
you know olive oil or any thoughts
i think you know listen i've been on a
lot of clubhouse talks lately i've heard
you talk about this a lot and one thing
that you echo is
a lot of nfts are not going to be the 69
million dollar success you know there's
a lot happening out there we got to be
really careful with
what makes sense for a brand
authentically i think right now in art
and auction the space that really makes
sense is
this is something that can um replace
those certificates of authenticity
can really do a lot of the heavy lifting
in terms of provenance and making sure
that the artwork we know where it's been
exhibited and who's owned it and create
that trail of provenance
it's really really valuable in the art
space i think for a small business
it's what is the thing with a lot of
valuable and intellectual property
that you potentially want to make unique
to your brand
so if there is something you're doing
out there that no one else is doing
how is there a way that you can use the
blockchain to authenticate that and to
own that in your space
it's you know for us it's really
scalable because there is a lot of
question marks in the art world around
provenance and other things for small
business i feel like there's less of a
use case
unless if there's something immediately
ownable that you want to make sure
everyone knows is yours and yours alone
none of these things go so fast i could
have another hour
thank you so much congrats on the role
congrats that the great timing of being
in that role and we wish you success
thanks for having me guys thanks neda
next up we have michael lastoria
ceo and co-founder of and pizza a
creatively led
mission-driven culture-first pizza chain
that was voted one of fast company's
most innovative companies
for social good referred to by bloomberg
as what jesus
might look like if he walked in a yoji
yamamoto show
astoria grounds and pizza in a
commitment to better flavor
quality ingredients livable wages and
real actions
and pizza has donated thousands for
local causes aligned with the company's
core values
welcome michael thanks for having me
gary good to see you brother great to
see you michael first of all can we nfp
your beard
is that something like i'd love to can
we have that discussion
it's great to see you
uh you know i think uh i'm really
excited to get your take on this i was
excited that you were part of this one
so i'm gonna get right into it uh
actually actually not true one minute on
a little bit of background
of and pizza because i think uh people
should be aware of it if they haven't
been yet
yeah so we have 50 locations spanning
from boston
you know down to virginia think about it
um and we're in new york city as well we
have three locations and growing think
about if domino's had sort of a distant
you know cousin that grew up in brooklyn
that cares about
living wages and environmentalism and
and really kind of reshaping the way
that fast food
has been built right off of high quality
jobs high quality food under social
conscious umbrellas so we're doing our
own thing marching to the video of
drummer and it's working and working
quite well so we're super excited we're
actually going to open up 25 new
locations this year and have 35 on the
docket
still look for us in a lot of cities on
the eastern seaboard to come
given given such an on-trend message
for so many of the humans on earth
when when we talk about the question of
like turning customers into
you know fans how does that how does
that play out in your in your mind
yeah i think a few things number one i
think it really helps to be
the chris driven company right having an
ampersand for us that stands for unity
uniting the working class as your true
north star right early on in the
pandemic and this is mid-march we were
the first company to raise employee
wages
guarantee employment strike a deal with
lift provide transportation from where
people work to the pizza shops
right use our food to feed hospital
heroes doctors nurses and ministers
cleaning staff and every time there's a
crisis we show up and we use our
platform our brand
and our food to do the right thing by
our people and communities
so that really goes a long way and i
think that coupled with
we built our own software stack our
entire communications platform is done
vis-a-vis text message we have
frictionless lead generation and organic
lead generation coming into the platform
every single day
and then using that creatively to launch
text-based flash sales the way that we
rolled out the hospital heroes program
in hero pies
is we had a daily lottery for the first
thousand that text us in
starting at 10 a.m every day right with
their actual employee hospital badge
we were giving free pizza too so systems
like that work extremely well i'm so
bullish on text message
i think brands are under utilizing it
across the board it's the most powerful
tool that we've seen and we've seen
hundreds of thousands of new customers
come through the text message platform
intra-coveted
that coupled with the moves that we made
the purpose-driven nature of the brand
and the fact that we had a software
stack that we could transition from
analog to digital
overnight and thrive in a time where
it's really hard for restaurants
the adversity of covid for a business
like yours
what non-scalable behaviors
or what little tweaks do you feel you
were able to execute on
that did create more fandom if any
yeah i mean a lot of it yeah a lot of it
was over communication i mean one of the
nice things when you have
a text platform you can communicate with
your customers instantly and you can
share with them what michael do you
think sorry
i'm sorry to interrupt you because now
i'm nerding out uh
what do you have a sense of what
percentage of people that come into
your restaurants you have their cell
number
yeah it now is around 60 percent
really that high yeah two-thirds of all
of our transactions are you
are you oh are you over incentivizing me
randomly walking by
a location in new york or boston i walk
in are you
over incentivizing me to give you the
cell number
well the the weight the reason why 60 is
a huge number
it's huge well number one you know
two-thirds of our business is digital
right so people are coming through the
platform ordering and our entire
communications is done through text
and the cool thing is unlike most brands
and we text out it's two-way
communication
so you can text us back we can actually
change orders mid-flight
so the fact that like the entire
platform is text message debate you
can't call us you can't email us
our entire customer service platform is
text so not only
i didn't i didn't realize it got it so
the whole communications
back understood unders and literally
michael like if i text i apologize but
i'm now really enjoying this
uh if i text like do you think the jets
will win this weekend
will i get a response or speak or
does that ebb and flow where you got to
take care of the problems first and this
and if there's an overflow
i might get a response or is it ai is
there humans behind it what's the punch
line there
yeah it's primarily human powered right
there is a little bit of sort of like
chat bot but that's only for basic
customer service questions around hours
yeah but you're getting humans and the
reason for that and eventually there'll
be some you know you know artificial
intelligence automation is that
it's very important for us to act like
human beings
communicate like human beings because
text the first time someone sniffs out
that it's actually not a real
conversation
is the first time that that person is
never going to text you again because
they're not going to believe in the
system itself
and so we will absolutely respond to you
if you ask who's going to win and quite
frankly
about 20 of all conversations are just
that which is have nothing to do with
pizza and everything to do with just the
personality of the brand itself
we love that stuff but we give full
permission right we call them the pizza
place
we prefer full permission to say
whatever you talk about fans
that's exactly right exactly and we have
a whole catalog of people texting us
post
like 12 a.m which is just absolutely
unbelievable it's like its own like
drunk text category
and it's just people we have a lot of
fun with it too by the way it's an
incredible job of transitioning from
the pizza shops themselves into
corporate like it's an incredible
intermediary job as people get
their legs underneath them and because
us as a brand that we hire for
personality
now you can work in corporate using your
personality
primarily to communicate with our
customers it's incredible and by the way
it's the same platform we use to
communicate with our employees and so
talk about having your ear to the ground
yeah every single day we have that
two-way communication so there's never a
time in a place where any single person
that works for us doesn't know
what we're doing how we're thinking and
how they can get in touch with us
michael dhruv from youtube says hey
michael i heard you
what does ann pizza offer that domino's
doesn't
so i mean high quality jobs high quality
food right if you walk into an aunt
pizza you'll see an assembly line so
similar to a sweet green or a chipotle
you can co-create your own pie and then
if you go to order.and pizza.com or
download the app you'll see a whole wide
variety
of categories our skin right looks a
little bit more like
netflix meets caviar so pizza categories
and categories within that all kinds of
crazy pies you can stumble across so
it's just high quality ingredients
different flavor you know profiles
healthier pies right we don't want to be
brand as healthy pizza per se
because it's still incredibly indulgent
and delicious and then of course
everything we do from a csr standpoint
is very different
talk to me about pizza culture for a
second was have we seen a rise in
anything
like you know for example i enjoy a good
slice of pizza but i'm like
totally anti the hawaiian pizza [ __ ]
like do not put pineapple on my pizza
i mainly did that because here comes all
the pineapple on
top of pizza people in the comments
section so i want to see who's pro that
did we see any trends at your end of a
new style over index under index
anything we're seeing
i think three three big three big trends
like indulgent american only with higher
quality ingredients
right people want like better stuff
number two
a heavy heavy heavy trend in vegan
right we have pretty sizable vegan
audience that kind of are some of the
biggest net promoters of the brand and
the third thing
is southeast asian right which
everything is having different spices
you're seeing the globalization of pizza
like you are everything play out in a
way where people are looking for
because then technically you can put
anything on top of right dough
and it can taste like delicious
depending on like where you're sourcing
the ingredients from so there's a lot of
flexibility we built the brand around
making pizza accessible for lunch and
the globalization of flavor profiles
michael i really appreciate you being on
the show brother continued success
you look great as always and uh and
thank you very much
thank you gary we love all things v so
thanks everybody
uh uh andrea before we move on to our
next guest i wanna just make myself
clear here
i'm a huge pineapple fan in a silo
it's when fruit goes into savory like i
love strawberries
do not want strawberries in my salad big
fan of grapes
take them out of my salad love pineapple
actually
by itself and even mixed with coconuts
for a little pina colada
do not put it on my pizza just wanted to
give that clarity to all the pizza and
if you're trying to see that recently
though gary you got to keep trying
you know i'm always pushing your things
all right
next we welcome heidi zack co-founder
and ceo of third love
the third largest online bra and
underwear company in america
heidi left her job at google with the
dream of offering a better option
a third love where women don't have to
choose between comfort and beauty
she is committed to advancing more women
in tech and is an
active angel investor in female founded
companies
fun fact heidi is truly a super woman
as she's an iron man at triathlete and
a mom welcome heidi
thanks for having me hey heidi how are
you good and i totally agree with you
about the no mixing fruit with regular
food like
tote 100 on your on the same page as you
and i'm obsessed with them separately
but when the mix happens i get a little
weird
agree heidi give out one minute on uh
what third love is and then we'll go
into how we turn these customers
into actual fans not just good customers
i want to get into that part
which we haven't yet yeah so third love
is a direct to consumer 100
online brand the only place you can buy
third love is thirdlove.com
and we built an inclusive brand
before that was kind of the norm i think
we pushed
an industry to totally change how they
sell bras and underwear
and we really focus on fit so we're the
only brand in the world that offers half
cup sizes like shoes
we have 80 bra sizes instead of 40 like
the average bra brand
and lastly we have a fitting room which
is an online tool to find your size
so that's kind of the core tenants of
third love
let me go to two places we haven't
touched on yet to create a complete show
and yes for all the people in the
comments on linkedin this is live
uh it is 12 21 pm on thursday it is
eastern it is live uh
heidi um when was the first time you
remember
doing something out of the ordinary in
those early days
to create a customer into a fan whether
it was taking care of a
you know a problem with a delivery or
something surprise and delight or
had you had you done any you know
hearing your google background
you know i always wonder where people go
into the black and white the math the
excel the tech
versus the gray right like i did
something early in my career where i
drove a case of 30 dollar wine
in a snowstorm to a customer because i
was trying to make a point to my 50
employees who watched me leave the store
on the busiest day of the year
for something that wasn't worth any
money so i'm just curious if you did
anything automated
or you know hand-to-hand combat early in
third love's career
that that touches on this subject that
we're passionate about which is
turning actual customers not to better
customers but the fans which is
a whole different game huge i mean one
this is qualitative i think all the best
stories are qualitative around
becoming a brand that women are like i i
don't i'm never gonna buy anything else
right and that's the goal
um we had a customer named hope she's
about 50 years old this is about
four years ago and she emailed our
customer service team which got
forwarded to me
and basically in this email she said i'm
a huge customer she sent a selfie of
herself and her t-shirt bra she said i'm
50 years old
i look great i love your bras i just got
your catalog
in the mail so we were sending direct
mail at the time and she's like i was
paging through it super excited and
every single person in the catalog
looked like they were 30 or under
and i'm annoyed basically she's like
that's like look at me i look great like
why don't you
she's like [ __ ] you basically you know
and she's was a great customer
yeah was annoyed at us and it got sent
to me and my head a creative and i got
together and we're like
she is totally right so not only do we
reach back out to hopefully people talk
yep but with her um we said to her hey
like listen why don't you fly up here
she lived in down
south in southern california why don't
you fly up to san francisco
and be a model in our next shoot yeah
we put her in our next catalog she was
on social media on her website
so hope not only as a customer but
became a
person that was part of our community
our brand and from that day forward
we've been much more age-inclusive and
that was something that's really
important to us so
you know you'll see models who are over
50 because women who are over 50 wear
bras too they look great and they're
part of our community and so
that was just a moment of listening and
and changing based on what we heard
i love that um speaking of listening of
what you hear i'm reading all the
comments keep them coming everybody
and i heard my hoodie was rubbing on the
mic so i took it off and that's why i
have a t-shirt
starting to step away for a second heidi
uh what is the
you know you're much bigger company now
uh as you keep building
what is um what is the
current state of strategy around turning
2021
ltv aka active customers and new
customers
from customer to fan anything brewing
any innovation anything on your mind
yeah i mean two big things that are
already happening and that we'll
continue to do more of this year one was
new categories i mean at the end of the
day
women and what they're wearing stating
the obvious are they're wearing much
more
wireless and lounge and all of that so
we've launched all those products over
the past
month and a half and so that's super
exciting and then second is humor and i
think you could really relate to this uh
we launched a new campaign called your
boobs deserve third love
and it's women with life-size bras it's
about two and a half minutes on youtube
it has over half a million views at this
point
and when we set up i apologize to
germany on the half a million views
uh uh paid media or organic
because both are awesome i'm just
curious my own self both
i mean definitely where the cuts of this
are on tv so if you're watching
women's history you know women shows on
hulu or linear tv you're probably seeing
the 15 or 30 second cuts of this two and
a half
minute long form content it's on it's
across the board it's our first fully
integrated marketing campaign so i'm
super psyched about that
and when we took a step back last year
in the middle of the panda back and
we're like we need a new campaign we're
like what's missing from the bronze
underwear market and what's missing is
humor
it's levity like sex has been used to
sell bras and underwear
like from the history of woman and
mankind but nobody uses humor
so this whole the whole thing is about
like how funny it is
that women have these like personal
relationships with their bras so in
in if you watch the segment you see a
woman she's on a date you think she's
talking to a guy
it pans out and she's actually talking
to her bra being like you're letting me
down and
eventually throws the drink off so you
know it's
just like let's just like like be a
little more real
no yeah exactly so that's what it's
about i i always felt that bro
that brands and brand managers and cmos
and
owners tried to make their brand so
narrow yet
we as humans the reason most people like
us is the combination of four different
things oh i like your ambition
and your kindness and a little sense of
he like it's
fascinating to watch people try to box
brands in when i think brands have
incredible
room to breathe absolutely
what about let's put this upside down
bring people
more value on the other side when have
you felt yourself in your life
go from customer to fan
i'll give you a second because i really
want to give you like a chance to really
think this through
where in your entire life do you think
if you can recall
converting from user buyer to something
that became more of like an advocate and
fan and cheered for the business or the
entrepreneur
do you have any thoughts i mean
i am very tied to all my angel
investments i won't talk about
it but you can i mean listen
i think it's a listen that's your real
life i asked you the question obviously
you didn't put money in just to quote
unquote make money you have an emotional
tie whether to
i heard it in the intro a female
empowerment movement or you just love
the product so give me one of each maybe
one or two of the angels and then just
again maybe when you were nine and it
was lucky charms or
seven you know i hear you're this crazy
athlete was there a sneaker that changed
your variable or you know something like
that
yeah i mean as an angel investment i'm
an advisor to a company called bobby
it's a new formula company it's bringing
european grade formula
to women and men in in the us
and i think there's a huge need but what
they've done really really well
is there's the emotional um
levity that happens when you're a new
parent trying to get your baby fed
and especially if you don't have enough
milk all these things and they've
really through everything they do just
try to create that conversation and
connection with their community in a way
that i don't think has been done before
in the space
and it's really really powerful and some
people hate on it because
for different reasons but they have a
very strong stance and a strong voice
um love that you know i would say most
recently as a customer
and i was just talking to the ceo um
last week so
bomba socks and dave and i were having
telling him i'd like literally just
replace my whole
sock drawer just like people do with
bras and so that would i would say as a
category
of me becoming a super fan and it all
goes back to product like at the end of
the day
it's like third love better product
that's what delivers
the value to the customer were you aware
of him because you ran in similar
circles did you see an instagram ad and
tried it like
do you have any sense of how that went
down i told him this it's funny yes of
course i've known him i met him a few
years ago i
follow them on instagram i get their
emails i never converted
and one day i was driving it was on
serious i keep hearing his ads all the
time and finally around the holidays i
not only bought myself but i gifted it
and then that turned into the whole
thing
i love that it's so funny i'm so hot
on spotify self-served new ad product
i'm obsessed with audio
spotify at third love too it's been it's
been i think i think
i think the voice feels
i mean this is why radio worked for all
those years so anyway heidi
continued success thank you for coming
on good to see you gary
cheers next up we have barbara messing
the chief marketing and people officer
at roblox barbara leads the innovation
and growth strategy
establishing roblox is one of the most
beloved brands in the world among
kids and teens prior to roblox she was
the cmo of walmart us
and trip advisor and she currently
serves on the board of directors for
overstock.com
and diamond resorts welcome barbara hi
how are you hey barbara how are you good
i mean talk talk about fandom this brand
geez that you must be
loving life to uh to be at the helm of
this
because talk about true passion uh
roblox has just an incredible fan base i
mean this is where the product really
just
nails this question but um how long have
you been there
i've been roblox about six months that's
what i thought so
maybe a fun way to start before we go
into it because i think it'll be very
native to this brand
um what's been the biggest shock or
interesting tidbit or surprise because i
know you probably came in very
you got educated you did your homework
you did your thing but you know how it
is no matter what
there's always something once you get in
in anything stand out
uh as a interesting observation six
months in
yeah i think so i mean one of the
biggest um
things that i'm really excited about
roblox is how big the ambition is of the
brand um i think everyone knows roblox
as kids and gaming and you know we're
obviously huge with under 13s and teens
i think where um roblox is really
exciting is really about this notion of
the metaverse
which you know a year ago if you were
like tell me about the metaverse i'd be
like really
but i'm really um amazed by just how
quickly the metaverse is taking taking
shape
and how roblox is shepherding it in and
i think all these amazing new
experiences we have on
roblox is really telling that story
about how people are living their
digital lives like very much the way
they live their lives in real life
and so i think just that trend and
watching it come to life has been kind
of mind-blowing
because of that and for everybody you
know this starts getting
metaverse starts getting into these nft
dynamics um
are you finding yourself trying to
explain the nft craze to a lot of people
because you have such depth of context
because
of the behavior that's always happened
in this ecosystem are you finding
yourself with
friends families contemporaries i'm
assumed
this you've probably been pinged many
times in the last 100 days around this
um is it is it funny to you that
you know 100 this nft thing is going to
happen because of the human behavior
in the metaverse in your world like is
that been like a fun moment for you in a
way because i think
i'm sure for you and the executives in
the organization it's kind of like
duh of course this is gonna happen i
think what's interesting for us is you
know virtualized virtual currency
virtual items you know that is really
like how roblox has been built and i
think digital natives really understand
that
um your identity and how you dress and
uh you know how you show up with your
friends and hang out
so much of that is very native to many
people as being just as
valuable and important in the virtual
world as in their real lives
and so i think that's the super
interesting thing is
i think there's a set of people where
this concept of like well is that real
or is that as valuable
like they don't get that but if you've
grown up and you really feel like this
identity you created is just as
authentic and true to yourself as it is
um in your real life then
it feels very natural and you know we
have tons of content creators on roblox
we have an incredible marketplace
and so for us it does feel very natural
that
you know your attribution your
providence that would be really
understood
to be important and that you know it
from the beginning i mean that notion of
really authentic creation has been
quarter roblox so it's been really
interesting to see this really
um take off i mean you're right in the
last few months it's sort of one of
those topics that's exploded
but uh in your career which is amazing
uh give us a story or two of like really
watching with your own eyes and action
whether through marketing
through customer service of truly
targeting somebody
from a customer to a fan which i think a
lot of
my fellow executives tend to think of
that
in the terms that i think which is they
see it as
a customer to a better customer and i
think there's a big leap
to being a fan because now you're an
advocate you're a fanatic
you're almost irrational any thoughts on
that
yeah i mean i think when you get like a
real insight and understand like hey
why what are we doing on the brand level
to make people really
love us more and are we really
understanding what their needs are are
we really building
for them right as opposed to what's good
for revenue
and i think the best brands really
design first with the customer in mind
and know that
you know your traffic's going to come
your revenue is going to come i mean
roblox is
classically built on um viral loops
right so you have the creator economy
where you have 8 million creators who
are building up experiences
that they themselves will love that they
think are cool
and then you have an incredible
community of people who are coming
because their friends have invited them
and they want to hang out with their
friends in these experiences
and then you know more creators come
because they see that that's where the
communities are
more people come because there's more
experiences different types of
experiences
um and so i think that's when it's
really sort of
built because of because by and for the
community is just say it
and you know you know in my career i've
been lucky to work on
other brands that have also been very
community driven
and it's really fun i mean you know what
ends up happening is they start to
spawn the growth of of the brand and
you know again as long as you keep
focusing on like building for them i
think that really helps
barbara why do most companies and
entrepreneurs on this
video stream right now not do that
in your opinion honestly i mean right
because it seems
so basic and you and i we're big boys
and girls now in our career
yeah we see so much behavior that isn't
that what are the cliche reasons and the
watch outs
that you've seen in your career to not
of why people don't do that or things
they do or things of that
yeah i mean i'm sure i would love to
hear your thoughts on this too i mean
you obviously
have built your brand i mean super
authentic really transparent i love
seeing what you are posting um always
let me let me jump in to give you
another second
yeah to give you a second to think about
your for me it's people
are either forced to because they're a
publicly traded company or they work for
somebody
to have to overvalue short-term monies
the and not actually build a long-term
relationship in on you know so in your
world
you're a major executive and you've got
a board
or a ceo or what have you who's holding
you accountable subjectively on
short-term business goals
which then will create for you not to be
able to do that for a lot of people that
are watching that are entrepreneurs
they want to make more money this year
to buy a nicer boat
or car instead of putting that money
back into the business and build
something long-term
so for me the reason i've seen you know
that we even have to say things like do
it for them
focus on them for them like i don't want
to make another
piece of content creative on television
or on digital that isn't something that
somebody doesn't want to see
like the reason people make that mistake
is they're worried about the short term
yeah actually i mean i agree with you
completely on that i do think the
amazing thing about roblox is we have a
founder who's been building this for 15
years
and so this is the opposite of um a
short-term
revenue focused company which is amazing
i mean we have been
always focused on the long term and one
of our core values is take the long view
and again like if you're building a
metaverse and creating a category that
hasn't been done of course but i agree
with you i think
um i think that sometimes people get
focused on the short term
fortunately that's not the case with
roblox and i even think with tripadvisor
you know very founder-based companies
very much focused on building for a
sustained long-term business
um but yeah you're right it's very much
founder and ceo driven
and i think within the company though i
think really having the customers
at the center bringing the insights is
really important and i think that's
where
if you lose sight of you know what are
you trying to solve for like who are
who is the sort of the bread and butter
what's your you know magic moment you're
creating every day for those customers
um staying close to that i think is
super important
did anybody win you over as a fan as
you the customer during covid or let's
say
if not over the last five years anything
stand out when i say
when did you become a fan of a brand
yeah i mean i would say
this is i mean this is going to be an
obvious one for people in tech but i
think tesla is an incredible brand
um just because the innovation built
into the product
and the delight factor i mean there's
some stat where like you know you're
really excited and then you get the
thing and then it's kind of like yeah
you don't really care
and i think that um that is you know a
daily use
product which is always super delightful
and
it's because it's really focused on
creating something new and unique and
also sustainable
and so i love the values of that um
of the tesla brand just because i think
the product delivers and i love sort of
the sustainability of of what tesla's
doing
barbara thank you so much keep up the
good work i'm so excited to see what
you're going to do through this next
journey
as metaverse and nfts become top of mind
top of tongue thank you for being on
thank you bye next we welcome
john henry co-founder and co-ceo of loop
john is a dominican-american
entrepreneur and investor
named the forbes 30 under 30 among many
lists and awards
born and raised in new york city john
dropped out of college at 18
where he picked up a job as a doorman he
went on to start and sell his first
business
at 21. he later co-founded the venture
capital firm harlem capital
raising 40 million dollars and making 20
investments in women and minority
entrepreneurs he was the host for tv
show hustle on vice land produced by
alicia keys and marcus samus
samuelson welcome john
thank you for having me john how are you
brother what's up man good to see you
thank you of course john let's get right
into
the beef event actually up front what
when you hear the term like
hey businesses you obviously have
invested in a lot
you're extremely entrepreneurial you're
a consumer um
you i think you're an extremely good
networker so i think you're
i think you're learning from the streets
kind of like i did more so than
you know a university of how to do
business and so
i'm actually just genuinely curious how
do you interpret this question
do you believe that companies understand
fandom versus just better customers
when have you gone to fandom what have
you done right or wrong in your
businesses what have the 40
investments you made done right or wrong
give me a john henry manifesto for three
to five minutes on this
yeah no i think it's a super good
question i think at the corporate level
my first inclination is to believe that
corporates don't truly understand how to
activate
an emotional response from your customer
and that's because
there is an uh there's an over
prescription
of uh assessing marketing via
numbers and i think that at the end of
the day you have to respond
and uh resonate with your customer
deeply at an emotional level
so for example when we look at our stats
yeah it's easy to look through
click-through rates and
and conversion and shares and likes but
what about some qualitative assessment
what about
you know when someone takes time out of
their day to write a paragraph response
i pay attention someone took two minutes
from their you know what they were doing
to craft the response and you know
whether it was
you know uh for what you were saying or
against what you were saying
it's that emotional response so i think
ultimately
you know caring deeply about the
customer is what's going to
transcend any kind of uh quantitative
assessment of the customer
of course you have to have your paid
infrastructure in place and all these
things to measure your effectiveness but
ultimately
i think resonating deeply do you think
that's a do you think that's a very big
challenge for startups that you play in
that world
because they're usually trying to get to
certain numbers to raise more capital
i have found that a lot of startup
founders love to talk this [ __ ]
and make fun of corporate and straight
up they're worse at it
because all they give a [ __ ] about is
getting to a number to get them the next
round of fundraising i have a very funny
feeling that you have a real hot take on
this because you've been in the depths
of that
world curious your take on that yeah i
mean i learned this from you to be
honest
back in 2014 when i discovered your
content and you hit me with the line
that was depth over width
and i started to really understand that
the fastest way to grow lukewarm
is to have lukewarm economics work and
throw a bunch of paid behind it to get
to scale
it's an unsustainable scale the true
scale that's long
lasting is built on resonance and
resisting the temptation to want to grow
quickly for growing quickly's sake and
instead dialing in your product and
service and for me we measure
smiles we measure shares we measure
people talking about us
and when you're starting to lock it in
then i think it's a little bit more
appropriate to put firepower behind it
so i definitely think that venture is at
a
is that a crossroads um i think that you
know
the the amount of capital going into
seed rounds the average seed round has
grown from 1.5 to 2.3 2.5 million
dollars the average valuation has gone
from four to five to six to eight
sometimes ten to twelve
so like seed has seen as an incredible
influx of capital and i think
you know i think uh [ __ ] will hit the
fan when it comes to the series a
there's gonna be a series a crunch and i
think the best practitioners will stand
out but at that point
with lupe what are you trying to do
differently on
fandom instead of just customers that
you haven't done
in your entire career whether it was to
doorman
to investor to personal brand like what
what what is your what have your
journeys taught you that allow you to
kind of now apply them to your latest
you know co-ceo ship co-founder in this
startup
yeah we're going to go all in our
community i really
really deeply believe in community as a
moat and i i had the unique
chance to chop it up with miguel
mckelvey from wework
and he had told me something that really
stuck in my mind he said john
when you look at your product if you can
develop an array of positive experience
that is how when someone walked into a
wework space it felt fundamentally
different from a regis
because they chose buildings that were
on the corner and got light from two
sides and that you can see light from
wherever you were and had a cup of
coffee always waiting for you
and so in that way we're an insurance
company but we're a mobile only product
and we move with you through time and
space
and that's a really unique opportunity
to
bring you from the online application
that is looped to some offline
activations
so i think really really deeply leaning
into community is going to be the mo
it's going to be why you stick with loop
for example i'm willing to put money
where my mouth is
uh and we're opening up uh 100 of our
customers have the opportunity to buy
equity in loop
as an example of like we really want to
push the mold
and really deeply care about the same
communities that we're ensuring i think
ultimately that is what we're seeing as
fandom is community
and and creating you know i think with
the nft space where people can be able
to get a piece of
the royalties of a band or an artist
and with all the law changes on who's
accredited investor you're going to be
able to take advantage of that
and create that from the forefront right
100 and we don't need
you know the community to be our
rainmaker like we're still raising
institutional capital
but to carve out a 25 50 100k uh
trunch in our round and have that go to
our same customers so they can
participate in the growth with us
super meaningful to me because you know
by the time a retail investor gets
access to airbnb's ipo
you know you've already missed out on so
much value creation so this is something
that i'm super passionate about
do you have any concerns about the
amount of money that's going to be lost
because people are going to think about
like oh i missed the ipo of coinbase
and yet you and i know 99 of these
businesses can go out of business
these are very high risk um you know
investments you know it's funny i
started getting excited about nfts
you know half a year ago i started
talking about it louder
90 days ago and about 15 days into
talking about i'm like oh [ __ ]
i've got to make sure that everybody
understands this is internet stock 2000
and 95 of these projects are not going
to be good investments or
are going to have a big bubble burst
with supply and demand issues and then
maybe long term
any thoughts on that when you when you
open that up are you going to try to
go because you could lose your community
when there's a down round and things
like you know you might have cut you
know
people think of all the upside like yeah
we're going to have an awesome company
i'm going to go public and everybody
who's an early user is going to make a
ton of money
imagine if you were an early user of
uber you would have made that right the
problem is
when the economy turns and you have to
do a down round and then everyone's like
yo i put in money
you know how do you think about that
things because there's a way to be
we're talking how to like make enemies
not fans
you think about that you know what i
hadn't even considered the the
potential of a down round which just
tells you that i'm in like fast i love
it you're like yeah yeah
no but but i think it's i think i think
the hedge up front is important be like
yo we think we're going to win
but do not get confused this is not like
buying a stock on
wall street this is a very very very
high risk we think we're going to take
you to the moon but you know
you know invest through real education
we'll give you as much information as we
can
yeah i resonate with that messaging and
i think ultimately you know we we have
the most
skin in the game i mean i've put in my
horse listen i think
one good note too is that the community
is likely less interested
in the profit outcomes and more
interested in the idea
of ownership and equity which has
definitely hit the cultural side guys
especially no questions of color
you want to be part of whatever it is
that you're supporting and i think it's
a cool vehicle to
to do that although we're not i want i
want to make sure that people don't get
destroyed on ideology
because you're right not only
minorities and people of color youth i
mean if you were 13
the amount of the amount of 13 to 18
year old boys and girls
in america and around the world but in
america because it's an entrepreneurial
dna
that view themselves as entrepreneurs
emerging influencers and investors
is [ __ ] staggering
like it's like hard to find one that
doesn't think of themselves as at least
one of those three if not all three and
that is a
you know talking to a 45 year old male
who lived
that life at 13 to 18 and couldn't find
anybody to even believe in anything
besides college
i think i'm bitter because i would have
been flexing like crazy in grammar
school
if this was like the ethos
you know and i wonder what that output
means for like the next
working generation you know like
employment has shifted so much
um it's mostly a work from home economy
and you know it's going to be exciting
to see um but
you know i just want to say lastly here
that content strategy
has has played a really really big part
and we subscribe to the volume strategy
as you've preached for time
uh and just like the real output of a
content strategy is when you go
to local spaces people approach you and
they have context on what you're doing
you know social is the actual plumbing
to human connection in today's age
so um thank you for having me it's been
super super great it was great just
looking forward to it keep pushing
peace next we welcome dino bernacci
cmo of the cleveland browns dino has
made a career
engaging with brands he believes in
holding rock star positions including
the cmo of mazda and leadership
positions at harley-davidson and general
motor motors
and now the nfl his dream job since he
was a kid
one fun fact his greatest passions other
than his family
sports and music are data and comic
books
i like that i need a better opening
after listening to john for crying out
loud
dino you have the best opening let
everybody who's watching this knows
exactly what's about to happen this is
going to be 10 minutes
of pure explosive family this is this is
actual fandom that might have
customers instead of what everybody else
is trying to go to
so i'm excited you're here i've got all
sorts of feelings
and conversations that i want to have
with you but how are you my friend
i'm great i i was looking at what's one
thing that doesn't look like the other
it's
me in this group yeah because we have
i won't say fans we have fanatics
they're just raving fanatics
that love everything about this team
yeah i think to that point
flip it on me knowing your background
andrew just mentioned it
this is the first time and to your point
i do think you're dif roblox
maybe a little bit but not to this level
you are starting from
fan then customer in a very very like
nobody on this call will ever achieve
the fandom level that you
sit at the helm of from a marketing
standpoint but that has its
ramifications
when the organization has gone through
what this organization has
gone through over the last you know many
years what what are the downsides
of extreme fandom when there's
in that you know every year everybody's
disappointed except for one team
obviously last year last year was a
great year especially by brown's
standards over the last 30 years um
give us a little insight into that yeah
i mean
listen i know a lot of brands are
criticized ours is
always out in the open and by the way
you know you might read about wins or
losses when it comes to others
you definitely hear about wins or losses
when you're a team and whether
you make mistakes or what is said or
done
there is not a bigger stage you could
sell me on than the nfl
and the fact that we are on that stage
and
we we have to address our fans after
every single game
yes we sit in front of media but who do
you think we're really talking to
it's our fans explaining how the game
went why it went a certain way
what we're going to do differently you
know
listening to the previous individuals
you know they talk about
emotion and rationalization there's zero
rationalization
when it comes to support it's all
passion you know
i am literally bizarro reverse gary in
real life
high energy but incredibly practical
just like wildly when you get to know me
like so i've built good businesses
jets gary
[Laughter]
i like love people i'm like i love
people i love people eight years ago
that's like two minutes ago i'm 37 years
old eight years ago
i'm walking after a jets game a
12 year old child wearing a tom brady
jerseys walking by me
and you know i into a fence
this is abuse this is this is assault
his dad turns to me and wants to gauge
and i look at him you know and say what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do about it
like that is not a normal person you
know that that's uh that's an obscene
amount of commitment which a lot of fans
have and and
you know we've been around for 75 years
gary we we've had some great runs and
we've had some struggles and
you know our the name of this team
is a cleveland browns right cleveland
and
that's we are part of the community you
know we talk about community which
a lot of people think of social we are a
pillar in this community
and people wants to be a part of it and
this is the one thing
you can really be a part of you can wear
the jersey
you're going to cheer like you just
talked about with all of your heart for
something and that passion and that love
is what so many brands try to proclaim
and it's really hard there's a select
few there's apple
that people just love i was at harley
davidson and i was telling you
they're fanatics you know they love
that brand when you're a sports team
especially on the biggest stage
almost in the world with the nfl i mean
it's a distinct honor but i'll tell you
it comes with a lot and and so what do
you do you know what do we do
uh you can take away the name cleveland
browns
it just heightens or elevates what we
have to do as a team and i'll say even a
brand because we are
is it's simple gary and i'm a simple guy
you got to listen
you got to learn and then you got to
leverage
and who are you i'm sorry you're
interrupted i have a really interesting
question
unlike a lot of businesses
when you're talking business with brand
sponsorships
yep people buying sweets you know
what you just said is exactly right but
is dramatically
more controllable in other businesses
you on the are on the business side
and you've got these business
conversations and the person on the
other side
is pissed because you went four and
12 or you went seven and nine or you
know like you know
talk to me about the variable of like
with harley davidson
like you know if they didn't love the
latest release or something you can go
and really talk to
the company and be like hey can we talk
about the handlebars or this and that
with the football team you can't walk to
the gm as the cmo and say i need you to
trade out the safety
or why didn't you get signed carl lawson
this week you can't do that [ __ ]
no but let's talk about sponsors because
i think that's a really good one
you can't you're right i can't control
as much as i would love to
what's on the football field they're
very glad that i'm not controlling
what's on the football field because
they do a better job
but i can control how close i get us to
our fans
i can control the amount of engagement
whether
we perform or we don't perform on the
football field i can control
what i can give as a as a sponsor
in connecting with the browns because
last year was amazi
amazing but it's a moment in time we're
75 years of rich history that people
love
and whether we're performing or not as
long as we're out there playing and
trying we're gonna
we're gonna sustain that love now i
understand when the field
doesn't perform it's like when a product
fails you
are you gonna immediately walk away or
how is it that you're responding
to your fan base what are you doing or
showcasing encouraging
that this is a moment of time that we're
learning that we're improving it's
candidly you know if you have a poor
product it's a poor product you can't
run away from it if you do it's a lie
and it's not authentic that people are
going to call it out
i think it's what you do in those
moments and candidly
what you share and you say with honesty
and earnesty
to those individuals you're right we had
a rough
drought for a period of time but man
you know that's an understatement well
listen
it was a rough drought for a period of
time i think that's one of the great
droughts of all time do you know
it is it is but you know what our fans
didn't walk away
no our fans stayed behind us they came
to the stadium they wanted more
and and the thing that at least you know
our ownership has been able to showcase
and and prove is we've been putting
those puzzle pieces together and i think
you know it gary like any
brand nothing turns over you know
overnight
nothing and doesn't but if you make good
decisions you leverage those you
showcase those you talk about those
you build dare i say content in and
around them
you can have people embrace and still
believe
and you know and you know this it also
then crosses over even
in adversity you can cross into this
different place i mean
i still believe that the red sox and cub
fan base was the most interesting
because of the nature of the drought
i have always adored browns and lions
fans
because of and as a jets fan with that
adversity
right like you know to me that is you
actually compound
authentic fandom in times of adversity
without a doubt so and i'll tell you
this if anything i can
leave you with is we do a lot of our we
produce our own shows and contents and
i'll tell you what the x's and o's stuff
works great but you know what
one piece of content has stood above
all others it's a property we call
building the browns
and it's the human side of these this
team and this teammate that we do we do
every single year and you when you learn
who these men and these people are you
can't help but even get closer
to to the team itself you feel like you
begin to know
you know you know this one of the great
misrepresented
humans in our modern american society
is the athlete 98
of these men are the kind of men that
you want your daughter to marry they're
the best
the headlines and the extreme mainstream
media coverage over the last 20 30 40
years
has people incredibly confused on the
quality of
the man and women in wnba and soccer
like
it really breaks my heart actually it's
something i'm very sad about i think
people
go very cliche on football
players and every and others and
meanwhile
that the discipline the kindness the
community service yeah
the community it's absurd right yeah
it's it's absolutely
you're right i'm telling you having
having dealt with this organization
and the players do you want to talk
about the most giving individuals
who really to the community as well as
to their teammates
let alone what they put on the football
field is extraordinary
and truly are extraordinary individuals
you're absolutely correct and
our goal you know to get more audiences
to love the cleveland browns to get
passive fans to become active fans and
active fans become evangelists is
getting to know this team better and
getting them closer to their team
because truly
gary it's their team i love it dino
thank you so much good luck this season
thanks my man good to talk to you next
we have allie webb
founder of dry bar squeeze and most
recently beckett and quill
podcast host of raising the bar and new
york times best-selling author
and guest shark ellie was recently
recognized as one of
ink magazine's 100 women building
america's most innovative
and ambitious businesses a fun fact
she's passionate about
love after a rough divorce and major
life reset she just got engaged to the
love of her life
on sunday welcome allie andrea you
totally i'm so mad ally i was gonna come
hot with the congratulations i saw the
photo andrew get back on here i'm very
upset
i love this one i was so
in it thank you guys well i appreciate
it it's nice
listen it's nice to hear from everybody
it's been i'm actually in the process of
writing
like a memoir which feels weird because
i feel like i should be 80 writing that
but i
literally last night was writing about
the really dark
year like and this specific time in that
year that was really
really hard for me and it's just funny
to re live it and
where i am now compared to where i was
then life's wild
right as you know long and has so many
opportunities for so many twists and
turns allie thank you for being on
yes let's go to the dry bar days yeah we
got the incredible uh excitement
uh out of the way um talk about
real fans i mean i remember it yes
vividly living in the world
seeing oh wow this this is a fan yeah
reality when did you notice
customers becoming fans did you think
about that did it start off as like
enthusiasts
like bigger customers but then you're
like wait a minute there's fandom here
what's been your relationship
with with you know this notion of
customers into fandom
well you know i don't think i realized
you know what
what we had kind of inadvertently
stumbled upon into creating dry bar and
you know very quickly it would like
caught on into your
point about customers becoming fans it's
like i
you know i realized that like not only
do people love drybar and the experience
and getting a great blowout they really
loved
you i like everything about it they
loved my story i mean obviously we were
catering to women and i was kind of this
underachiever
who like found amazing success and you
know
thinking about coming on here today it's
like it's it's like
authenticity and relatability you know i
mean i
for the first like five
six years i mean i was in the stores all
the time and i was talking to
clients all day long and i would tell
them my story if they wanted to hear it
you know and i would talk to people and
you know i must have done this thousands
of times it just
like i loved it and they loved it and it
built brand loyalty and they wanted
not only did our our clients love the
experience of driver but they wanted to
get behind the brand because they liked
what the brand stood for they liked that
it was like
a mom an entrepreneur you know a
self-made woman
at the helm of it you know it was like
all of those things and you know when
things went sideways and they did
you know if someone didn't like their
hair or we had to raise prices or we had
to do things that
kind of sucked we we came at it with
this very authentic approach like we're
going to be transparent with you
if we mess up on your hair we're going
to tell you we're sorry and we're going
to publicly tell you you're sorry you
know i remember
you know over the years when when
clients would publicly like back then
when people were tweeting or
instagram if they'd be like i came to
dry bar and i didn't like this and i
didn't like that i would publicly
respond and my team would be like
why are you going to draw more attention
to this and i'm like well first of all
because
it's important that we tell this woman
that we're sorry and we want to make it
better and it's also important for other
people to see that like
we recognize that we [ __ ] up and we just
want to fix it you know and that
that i think that authenticity and being
real like
we're not perfect we're human and we're
doing our best here and we're going to
continue to do our best for you
i think all of that and i could i could
tell you so many more stories but all of
that stuff has like really created that
brand
loyalty and and i think that people felt
really connected to me
to the brand and i think that's that's
where it really all started
when um when you navigate your world
because you've had
these successes and and built
a brand so authentically around this
genre
you were you have you found yourself
post this experience with dry bar
be more hyper sensitive to the way
brands and businesses
do react right because that's you know i
feel like that happened to me
i could see right like i'm like like i
can't walk into a business without being
like
are you guys kidding me with this like
i'm giving you my money
why are you treating me this way like it
is it's actually always been a thing
because my parents had their own
business and my brother
my brother michael landa is my business
partner and we grew up in this mentality
of like
you know the customer is king you treat
the customer like gold that's
that was ingrained in us as kids so even
you know pre-dry bar especially like
working in the salon business and
the way people were treated if they
weren't like a celebrity or they didn't
have the right latest handbags and like
the salon culture
really bothered me and so yes i'm so
hyper sensitive
i think i'm more sensitive now to brand
because i learned that through drybar
and through my ex-husband because he's
such a genius when it comes to creating
that brand that now i'm like it's it's
like you could make three little changes
and your business would be so much
better you know and it's it's
like yes it drives me crazy and i want
to go in and fix
so many doors i walk into what about the
reverse what about in the last year two
or three
or you could take us way back a brand
that really actually converted you into
a fan
instead of just a customer any stories
on that front yeah for sure i mean i
think there's sometimes
you know when i've you know when you
walk into a place and they you know they
bend over backwards for you
and if they to my earlier story it's
like if they if something goes wrong
and they figure out a way to fix it and
you feel like somebody who's there
working there really cares about it i
mean you know i mean i was just in
a store this past weekend i was shopping
and you know shopping is like
you can't you're just being able to
start doing that again i was so happy
the store is open i was shopping this
girl was great
and she was bringing me clothes and she
was really attentive and and i asked her
i said are you the owner
you know and she said no but i really
appreciate the compliment like of course
she did because
she made me feel very taken care of she
was bending over backwards for me she
was giving me options she was engaged
but not annoying you know and it's like
she had that right balance and so i
naturally assumed she was the owner
because that's usually what you get from
an owner
versus an employee which is really the
rub and the hard thing about
having you know a business like ours
that has 4 000 employees it's like
getting
you know it's it's hard a lot of people
yes
i spend most of my time on hr and how
people treat each other
even at 1300 or whatever we are in
vayner x now
it's hard it's hard it's hard you know
it's like how do you get it's hard to
get people
if they don't know it if they don't know
what they don't know and if they've
never been treated
a certain way you know i always had this
like fantasy of taking all of our
employees to like
you know the most high-end hotel where
you you know the hotel like the four
seasons or the ritz carlton
where they could where they could taste
it yes where it's like oh
[ __ ] people are really amazing to me
here and you know you've experienced
that i've experienced that where you
you go to a place and you're just you're
so well taken care of and it just feels
so good and
you know and i always wan i always
wanted our employees to experience that
because if you
live it you can then give it back you
know we both grew up with the same
mentality with
with the luxury of having parents that
have these businesses like to me
same thing like a customer over my own
self
like forget about employ like period uh
what would you tell because there's a
lot of aspiring entrepreneurs listening
not just executives here
do you feel that obsession of fandom for
customer
is a disproportionate superpower in year
one when you're a tiny tiny business and
you
are relying on that word of mouth i i
feel like i have noticed
people going from year zero to year one
have had
that a lot of people from a hospitality
mentality whether they went to cornell
and hospitality school but then started
a business or
parents that had a family business that
it's like that first year we're like
[ __ ]
every interaction is like everything
like you're so [ __ ] appreciative
and you so desperately need that person
to create some word of mouth
that has seemed to be you know i'm blown
away by people opening a store
and not going ham on their first
customers
and taking it for granted and i see
those businesses lose a lot thoughts on
that
yeah i mean i think that it is like you
have to keep the momentum going one way
or the other and i mean that was a
unique challenge for us you know it's
like i
you know recreating that moment where
it's like not just you as the owner you
know and i think that's also like really
empowering
you know like our our managers and all
of our stores you know we would give
them like
like a budget that was just like do what
you want with your
you know with your staff like in terms
of like but you know buy them pinkberry
on a on a friday because it's like busy
in the shop and
you know i think a lot of that starts
that brand
the client loyalty and fan it's like if
you're if your employees are really
happy and they love what they're doing
then that that just permeates into the
rest of the business that was something
that we would
really try to once we got so big you
know try to empower our
managers to be owners you know and i
remember having conversations with
managers over the years and they would
they'd be telling me something about the
shop that they run they'd be like so in
my shop and then they'd be like
it's yours it's not mine i'm like you
love that i love that like no no
i want you to have ownership
foundational for fans foundation
yeah so if they were they had that love
and that and it's like treated like
their own they were not only going to
treat their employees like they're
like their own but then the clients and
they take they take ownership in it and
they take pride
and that i think is is the thing is
getting you know whoever's running your
business when you get to that point of
that you're so big that you can't be in
it every day
is is you know that pride is and it's
hard to come by
i love it ellie i think you really laid
down some real core
foundational pieces here thank you for
your time congratulations and
we'll see you soon thank you bye guys
next up we welcome michelle harman
madsen the cmo of accuweather
she has held the senior most roles at
shoprx lab
fresh direct mediavest and 19
entertainment where she led sponsorship
for american idol
and so you think you can dance a couple
fun facts about michelle
she's a mentor to four women each year
and she can dock a 50-foot yacht
welcome michelle thank you andrea great
to see you gary
michelle it's great to see you before we
get into anything
why is weather so hard to actually
predict
like one of my like i've been friendly
through the years with a you know
a weather man or woman or two and it's
like you know
i find it to be one of the most
fascinating things on earth and since i
have you here now and i've got this ten
minutes i just
you know i figured you probably have the
answer now at this point like
what a wild game where people have like
massive conviction of what's going to
happen tomorrow
with incredible data and yet mother
nature is like
you know i mean mother nature is a
wonder into herself correct right i mean
you can't make anything up more wonder
when you think about this past week
you know we had huge snow or storms in
denver and wyoming like you know
breaking all kinds of new records and
then we've got
the southeast which unfortunately some
really you know thunderstorms severe
weather and tornadoes
but i think it's really what i love
about the weather is it's universal
and you know it's something that touches
all of everyone so today in new york you
know you and i we've got
kind of a little bit of a rainy day so
maybe our energy isn't quite what it's
used to i know right
but i will tell you my daughter is a
huge fan of a rainy day it's her
favorite day
i might prefer the snow but to me you
know thinking about as you're talking
about like listen it
impacts everyone i'll i'll tell you a
quick story so
when i was thinking about coming to
accuweather um
i came home from having some discussions
and i told my daughter who's in high
school so at the time i think she was a
junior or so in high school
and i said listen i'm thinking about
this opportunity with accuweather and
here's what i'm gonna do and she comes
stopped me cold
and she said mom weather impacts
everyone
that's cool and i thought to myself she
was right because it does it impacts us
all in ways that you don't even expect
i love that um when you think about
fandom
from a customer actually you know what
spend one minute to explain to people
who are your customers
because i think that might actually you
know uh matter
yeah now when i think about our
customers it's vengeance
even asking the question thinking about
it because to some extent we'd say gosh
everyone potentially could be our
customer because we literally it's a
global brand
we've got people everywhere but i think
what's also important to think about is
why people come to us
and that's to me what always kind of
hits my heart it's not sometimes they
need they want to
know hey what is going to happen today
what is the forecast but oftentimes
it's you know they may say gosh this is
my want i want this but it's more about
what they need down the road so i will
say
um you may come today um right now after
this you may say gosh i need a break i
need to get outside and you're gonna
take a look about
um you know is it raining the rest of
the day or can i get outside and give a
walk do some exercise
but you may also look at all right what
am i going to do this weekend what am i
going to do next weekend
you know can you plan some other things
around it and so i find that our
audience
are really they're active they're
participants they're doing things and
whether that is
gardening to um exercise to
frankly you want to get the kids to the
park and go to the grocery store during
a pandemic
it's about being active with your life
and those are our fans and
do you think a lot of people actually
you know you by nature
of your product makes sense that you
were able to go to that why
i think a lot of brands a fashion brand
like what am i trying to express to the
world
or or a food brand like why am i
actually eating that
do you think that the nature of this
business because obviously you've done
other things in your career
actually there's a big advantage there
that forces you and your other leaders
to really
really probably spend a ton of time on
why and do you think that's a
competitive advantage
yeah i mean listen we're we are a
purpose-based business there's no
question about it and so thinking a lot
about the why is really important to us
because it's about listen i want you to
enjoy 72 and sunny
um you know that's fantastic but we
really want to think
about how can we help you make really
smart decisions for you and your family
to stay
safe and that's a different kind of
proposition and so thinking about why
um and how we can better communicate
that and better
you know tell you about the impact is
really important to what we've got to do
from a marketing perspective as well
if i was if i was the ceo and came to
you and said okay
i need your number one kpi for 2021
based on where we are right now
is to turn more of our customers into
fans
and and left and said get back to me
obviously that's very kind of gray
yeah and i and if and if i abruptly left
you're like this [ __ ]
jerk you know like well how do i convert
but like if i actually said it in a nice
way and we sat together
what would you what would you think
about doing how do you how do you do
that
yeah well let me back up i'm going to
tell you um
so last year um i came on board
literally two weeks before we signed it
went home for covid
but we were um which was happening to
everyone but we were getting ready to
launch
a big launch for us we were creating the
new newly redesigned accuweather app
and so to some extent we were basically
taking all of our current fans and we
need to make them be new you know
and we of course want to grow it but one
of the most interesting
things about all right we're bringing
creative in-house we've got a brainstorm
from remote all those things that you
weren't used to
was we actually launched a beta program
for the app so we literally over 100 000
users around the world who were engaged
and these were fans these were new these
were techies these are early adopters
these were people who just said
gosh you know sign me up but what was so
interesting about that experience is we
really gained unique insights on what
was important to them
so everything from you know we changed
the
product roadmap we actually said listen
let's reinvent or re-put forward things
that made sense to them based on
feedback
it seems and really we thought about how
we were going to be thinking about
messaging for marketing
um we implemented different customer
service in different ways because gosh
that wasn't the questions we were
expecting
and so it was really about being attuned
to what the customers were
and we are still following some of that
roadmap today and so when we think about
customers it really is
i don't want to take my ball uh my eye
off the ball i want to keep them
forefront
and how can i make the rest of the
organization be as passionate about the
customers as we are
i've been enjoying this question what
brand has made you a fan
in your life whether as a young girl
recently
anything um anything stand out as
a time you remember going from maybe a
casual user or a heavy user
or a lapsed user or a non-user into
fandom
no i'll i immediately think of two one
is is um
i have to give some credit to delta of
late with they're continuing to do the
middle aisle of vacant
amazing how many people are saying i
want to go visit a loved one but i'm
flying on delta
and i think that's really interesting
that they really they're giving they're
giving up some of the dollars on that
but they're winning that game
mm-hmm i think so i think it's a
tremendous
i'm sorry since we're up but i want to
bring a lot of value on this show
because a lot of people are mid market
and lower marketing we have these big
wig corporates so a lot of my
that is a huge statement michelle thank
you for that giving up some short-term
dollars
to massively over-deliver for your
customer
builds real brand and long-term will
really matter yeah
and it's amazing how many people have
brought it up in conversation they've
said like my gosh i'm really impressed
they're still doing the middle seat
and and that's i i know i think it's you
know a lot of the airlines get
you know a lot of flack but i i think
that's been a big deal by the way
michelle real quick on
airlines getting black i think it's the
greatest
the greatest showing of human
entitlement in our society like
the we are so many people are scared of
flying
so so much of what delay delays are
built on
are on overly aggressive
safety protocol and people like
lose their mind and i'm like
this is so crazy we are so lucky
to be in a society where like when like
like
right before all of komen the wi-fi is
not working and i literally heard the
collective of the plane go
huh and i'm like the fact that we even
have wi-fi
on a [ __ ] flying piece of metal in
the air
the [ __ ] the matter with these people
like i actually think the anger towards
airlines is the greatest show of spoiled
culture
in the world i really believe that sorry
it really doesn't say that
you may be an interesting point it
really is first world problems because i
think
you know a lot of us you know you've got
to remember like if you think about you
know safety you just even
like it's not a phenomenal track like
what do you want like michelle
like it's way safer than driving a car
what do you want him to be like man
we're not quite sure about the wind gap
but [ __ ] it but michelle and gary gonna
be upset if they're late let's just go
with it
like what are people talking about you
know it'll be interesting seeing people
really change with all this stuff going
on and like i feel like the importance
of family
the last year and those connections you
wonder if people will take a little bit
of a deeper breath moving forward
because i do think people are bursting
at the seams to come out right now
they're like oh just get me anywhere
so we interesting to see if we see
change and will people be a little
softer gentler
or will be a little more edgier um
i think that's right michelle so much
fun great to see you again
wishing you success next up we welcome
jamie goodfriend
global cmo of mga entertainment a
high-growth
global children's entertainment and play
company with brands including little
tikes
rainbow high and the number one toy in
the world
lol surprise prior to mga jamie held top
positions at expedia
microsoft caa wpp and hasbro
and a fun fact jamie's a passionate fan
of the new york
giants oh that i was holding every
ounce that being said jamie uh
vaynersports
represents leonard williams and he just
had a big contract with your beloved
giants
so we can connect on that and real quick
i apologize i rarely do this but matthew
amir richardson said
but gary we paid for it on the plane
point i was just making
yes and you play pay for food and
sometimes it's 15 minutes late and you
get mad
this is a plane you're in the air matt
like do you want them to not
triple check or make sure planes don't
crash into each other
anyway jamie a real pleasure toys is one
of my favorite categories so
and i love your background this is off
to a good start how are you
i am so happy to be here today this
feels normal
whatever normal is after the last year
but i'm so excited and we have a lot of
uh friends who keep telling me tell gary
hi
same same your name's been bro i've been
i was really excited you're part of this
and i hope it's
the starting point to our friendship um
and you know
being a passionate football fan and
being in the toy category so much
you really got my attention i'm a huge
toy advocate from an ip standpoint
collectibles i'm sure
nfts are running through your head every
single day now with all the ip
opportunities there this is an easy or
conversation for you or the cmo of the
browns because you actually have fans
and then it's like almost business
backwards
versus a lot of the people we're
referring to which have customers that
are trying to turn into fandom
what are the watch outs what are the
pitfalls you've got this great career
you're at this company that you've been
at toy companies in the past
in your incredible experience what are
what is a tried and true method
to get customers into fandom and we're
new because we've seen this too
where do great brands lose fandom and
and just start getting back into
customer what are some of the missteps
just curious
just knowing we have your perspective on
that yeah you know and i think it's
interesting
sports is such a great metaphor for
fandom
and i also think investors are another
and i think if you look at both of those
it's all about the product
right and if and we start i mean i'm
really lucky so at mga
um you know i wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for the founder isaac larian and
40 years ago he had this
passion for product and that's what's
carried this company through for 40
years so just like
sports or a financial product
it's got to be about really good quality
so if your quality gets [ __ ] up then
that's going to be a problem
and you have kids right you have a i
heard tell that you've been an 11 year
old right so you've been buying a lot of
toys
you know all about these things so when
when
you get that product home if it's not
amazing
you know it and the war and the hardest
fans forget sports fans
kids you know there's no faking it it's
either
they love it or they don't and that is
it and you spent money and if it's not
great so
we really take uh a stand of making it
an experience
and i and i know that sounds like bs but
it's not it's like
get the package get the box get the
unwrapping the unboxing all of those
things
and then really trying to make sure that
we're over delivering and isaac always
says it's like
you know our our profit margin could be
a lot better
if we didn't spend so much on the toys
we don't want to disappoint kids
and i think that's a that's number one
it's smart it's clearly founder-led
it's all the same cliche things you hear
because in 80 years
whoever's running this company is not
going to have that same dna you see it a
million times over
you know you hope but it's very hard the
people that create those things
tend to give up money in the short term
because of their depth of passion for
that thing
you know with all this spak talk jamie i
i'm getting bombarded take vayner spac
take video i'm like
guys gals you do not want me to take my
company public
because the first time i have to be on
an earnings call as a public ceo
and some nerd from harvard and a hedge
fund says to me
why did your margin go down this this
quarter i'm gonna be like i don't know
[ __ ] nerd because i don't live in an
excel sheet like you
i'm running a real business and i'm
trying to build it for long term and
that when i hear you talk about that
that excites me
and to me that over everything is how
you build
actual fans yeah well short-term
long-term right and
you know we have this phrase it's like
venture consumers
so people want to feel like they know
what's going on in the company and that
they trust that you're taking
care of what's important and what's
important and what works for a public
company
doesn't always match you know that i
mean that's exactly what everyone's
going through a lot of companies that
have gone public
have seen what that's like because you
spend so much time
uh working easing the market all that
stuff and you can't really make the
decisions and i think what's interesting
at mga which is
frightening and and also really powerful
is the attention to detail
down to the minute of like the the
window is closing isaac and he's still
tinkering with the details of the toys
and it gives us all crazy and it's
literally to the last minute and we're
like we're gonna have to get a plane
from hong kong
or from our factory in ohio and ship
this stuff out and we're gonna
make less money just like it's got to be
perfect
so that's you know that's that's kind of
where we are i think the other
thing for us and again you have kids and
you're so savvy about the
world of the internet is this idea of
privacy
and taking care of kids um we've been on
this really interesting journey
work very closely with a company called
super awesome that was recently
acquired by epic yep and i think privacy
um creating fans when you're dealing
with families
privacy and you know being compliant and
really making it safe for kids
that is that is quality and privacy as i
think that's going to be a big
differentiator and that is something
that we're talking about every day
all day um interesting statistic i heard
that
um every day 170 000
new kids go onto the internet for the
first time
right it's amazing do you let your kids
go on onto the internet onto the
internet do they go to youtube
where are they yeah i'm a big believer
that the internet thing
is parents excuse for not building
self-esteem and parenting
properly and that kids are going to be
living in this world heavily
and the internet's not the demon it's
the actual work
that parents have to put in to actually
build a framework
to allow their kids to absorb
information i don't know what
fantasyland
parents live in when they when you know
kids have phones at 11
the hell do you think they're looking at
at school or like like this
this naivete and lack of accountability
jamie
of parenting that everybody's like [ __ ]
facebook or you'd like i'm like
[ __ ] you teach your kids self-esteem
like put in the work so anyway i got my
own
very interesting passionate point of
view on this
uh but because we lack of account we
lack accountability
and uh on a parenting framework and i
think we are asking the world to parent
and so i'm the beneficiary of the
greatest mother that ever stepped on
earth
and i know what that meant and i know
which mother hearing that is the nicest
thing you could possibly say that's so
great
jamie we act as if we didn't have things
we had plenty of things plenty of
bullying
on tv kate moss was showing girls to be
to look like all the things that we
it always existed no sunblock
and believe me i so we could get on the
whole millennial thing but like
but i think and that is a whole other
topic believe me when i graduated
college i'd rather live on the street
than
move home with my parents that was
living with you like
taking your parents money after the age
of 22 not happening
is devastating because it's not this is
not judgment this is
me loving that 22 year old and saying do
not do that like
live like dog [ __ ] you'll be so much
happier
an influencer and make millions of
dollars or
or jane because it's an important
sentence or 67
000 which is enough to get an apartment
with two for like you know what i mean
like anyway
we're go we're going in our tank all the
hype
through the years that we should be
friends has been affirmed here you
dropped an f-bomb you like football
we see a lot i like it last thing
you a fan what are you a fan of from
what brand has
converted you to a fan roblox and i know
you're talking about
veteran it's a game changer literally
and i mean
i mean that literally we've we're
investing in it big time for lol
surprise
it's community it's everything i'm so
excited to watch that
company and that brand they've just done
such a good job they over index on
privacy and experience and
i can't i can't say enough good things
about roblox
jamie looking forward to more times
together thanks gary andrea put us two
together we need to be real
real real and i'm gonna send you some
toys please
i'll send you swag i may sing it i may
sell them on ebay i'm that kind of
character okay sorry i just want to be
transparent okay
all about the flip next we welcome
samantha malton
cmo of the sesame workshop the
non-profit educational organization that
sits behind
sesame street samantha elevates sesame
workshops content
and deepens brand engagement with
consumers partners donors
and fans samantha brings 20 years of
global experience in media and
entertainment
with major brands including history and
nickelodeon
she and her husband have two children
who think cookie monster
works in the office upstairs welcome
samantha
thank you so much for having me hi gary
it's been so long
it's so great to see you so good to see
you you can't even imagine like my
like literally my cheeks hurt when you
know it's been like six seven years
you you i i just really like you a lot
and it's great to see you again and
you're sitting at the marketing helm of
one of my favorite ips
and platforms in the world so it's just
great to see you again
it's so great to see you you know i'm a
huge fan of yours
thank you so you know again
what's been fun about the way andrea and
team set up this lineup there are
certain people that just naturally come
in with fans
not just customers and i would say this
ip means that but
when you hear that the the statement
we're trying to do for today which is
how do we turn you know customers into
fans
how does that land in your mind and how
do you think about that
yeah well first of all sesame workshop
is a non-profit and
most people don't know that they just
know sesame street
the show so who's our customer children
and families
right and because we've been a
successful beloved brand for
50 years we actually have three
generations of sesame street fans
so we just actually finished a deep
audience segmentation study and we
zoomed out we looked at you know who's
our total addressable market it's
enormous it's like 170 million people
but we really wanted to deeply
understand who are those people
right so not just parents of
preschoolers but who is more likely to
stream our show you know and who's more
likely to donate
and then we looked at web behavioral
data so that we could actually
find distinct viable attributes to reach
them right so second
what are we giving them and you say this
all the time right it comes down to
great content
we could have the best marketing tactics
in the world and
if the content isn't engaging it doesn't
matter
but our content is grounded in rigorous
research
to understand children's developmental
needs and then the best ways to address
those needs
all while engaging them in playful
learning but i think third like
where we're reaching them and as a
non-profit this is where strategic
partnerships
are really critical for us right we
depend on our distribution partners
to get our content out we depend on
generous funding from our philanthropic
partners to elevate
our mission and of course we use our own
platforms right we have a massive
youtube platform to reach kids we have
our social platforms to reach adults
and we go deep in communities with on
the ground providers
but really it's the collaborations that
help us show up
in unexpected places like super bowl
with our partnership with doordash
um and that's that's really i think that
was powerful for us
at the end of the day oh i'm sorry no
how long have you been in the role uh
it's about a year and a half now
what what most surprised you because of
course like every other person watching
this you're aware of
it but what in that first 100 days where
you're like
oh now i get it or oh i didn't expect
that or
oh this is so much more epic than i than
i realized
yeah i mean i think it's about it's
about the fans
right it's about how um
our characters connect so deeply
to people and it's about how they move
through our brands
throughout their lifetime right not just
the brand touch points
but i mean look at me like i'm a mom of
preschoolers
right now i am living the brand day in
and day out and i have a relationship to
to this brand also as as a fan myself
from growing up with it but
what surprised me is how people stay
with the brand
even as their kids age out of it like we
have them for generations
um and that's the most important thing
for us right because
that's where we're cultivating um their
relationship to the brand and then
getting them to give back
and donate when um
you've obviously you know this is where
we intermingled like
you've been around other entertainment
i.p things of that nature
what what do you think it takes for a
business
to really push over to the other side
someone um from casual
to fandom you know a fan a fanatic
i remind people fan is short for fine
like that means
pat you know i think fanatic has a
negative concentration like
truly passion what do you think are
required to get there
look i think it's about brand
authenticity i think it's about
being real and giving your
fans all the parts of your fandom right
we have so many different sub segments
what they're looking for and and giving
them content that they connect with
right for us we're giving parents tools
and resources
to talk to their children about things
that are that they are meaningful we're
providing
you know educational content to
preschoolers but for fans who might not
even have children
we're connecting them we're connecting
with them in a way that's meaningful to
them like there was a tweet
the other day from cookie monster yeah
there's a tweet the other day from
cookie monster
and i was just reading some of the
responses you know it was like
me no cry because um cookie is finished
me smile because it happened and
something like that
i started reading the comments and i was
like tearing up one woman was writing
about how
she lost someone really dear to her and
that meant so much to her it made her
day
like just just being authentic yeah you
believe that this brand
you know what just hit me is like right
i was about to say
how do you get there but the reality is
such a staggering amount
of at least american i know it's an ip
that goes global
society actually grew up with it which
means even
at 12 16 which when you think you're too
cool for school
you know sesame street has incredible
potential to win on tick tock because
everybody was touched by it which means
you don't have to wait
until you're a parent of kids again it's
kind of
always in play as an ip to get people to
care
yeah look we have 99 brand awareness
that's unbelievable um but
it really is about being authentic and
connecting
with our different fan segments in
in the way that's most meaningful to
them so
i yeah sam talk to me about
you as a human and fandom outside of the
sesame
ecosystem what in the last one two three
years
has struck you has converted you from
the casual
to a fan and what was the story behind
that
oh what can uh you know look i i've been
um in the last five years i've gotten
married had two children moved to the
suburbs
um so for me you know i could barely be
getting a [ __ ]
and waking up getting a shower and and
having a little bit of sleep
one night full night sleep is is amazing
no but i mean
i especially you know during during this
pandemic
um just just seeing a sense of community
and resiliency
um is really what has struck me um
in terms of you know being a fan and a
fan of brands
like for me it's it's costco right like
i can get my
i can get my diapers my shiseido face
cream like all in one place
and they've made it incredibly easy
during the pandemic to
pick up or right i mean delivery like i
don't have to go anywhere
it's you know to me that that is what
i'm sort of living and breathing
um right now but i think just getting
back to
you know to where we're going um as a
brand and what's next i think
look at what's going on right now right
we're living in unprecedented times i
think the world
needs sesame now more than ever and it's
become so clear to us that we need to
help
parents and caregivers be able to talk
to their children about what's going on
around them i mean the wave of
of racism of xenophobia the spike in
in anti-asian hate and we stand with you
know with our community there
um sesame street was founded on the
principles of
diversity equity and inclusion it's part
of our dna and we feel this
responsibility to help kids make sense
of what's happening so what's next for
us
we're about to announce a major
commitment to racial justice
with a new educational framework the
abcs of racial literacy
and really give content to families to
help them
talk to their children about race and
identity so that's what i'm
super passionate about right now that's
awesome sam
uh final parting shot any time in your
career where you saw an
adverse moment in the company turn into
a place of opportunity that led to
fandom anything come to mind
oh an adverse moment um
turn to fandom i you know what i think
about without to give you a couple more
seconds to think
something doesn't land but then
self-deprecation or humor or
accountability has been deployed
which then turns the tide of people that
were most upset to maybe people that
became huge advocates
uh or maybe being on the receiving end
of that maybe maybe in that costco
journey
they got the wrong shipment and the way
they handle it i think that we think a
lot of times of like
i don't think people realize how the
most negative moment is
actually sometimes the moment that's
most open
to doing something that can create fans
it's okay if there isn't i was just
curious if there was
yeah that's tough one for for me to
think of off the top of my
off top of my head um for
for sesame i think um i think i go back
to
you know the challenges that sesame
started uh to embrace and i think
you know we i think that's where i go
with
with our next initiative right now
that's what we're so focused on
um i think we've faced that throughout
the years right sesame's always been on
on the cutting edge of sort of of
showing what
um what kids worlds look like all the
time
and i think um i think every single time
we've been criticized
um you know we've we've embraced that
and built it into
our um our dna sam it's so great to see
you again
oh it's so nice to see you we'll talk
soon
next up we have joey gonzalez the global
ceo of berries the original cardio
and strength interval workout joey began
his tenure at barry's as a customer in
1997
and he became an instructor soon after
worked his way up eventually becoming
ceo
in 2015. while continuing to teach class
joey continues to grow the brand
footprint domestically and
internationally
today berries boast over 74 studios and
more than 150 000
engaged consumers a week welcome barry
or joey thank you they always call me
barry
i answered to him are you are you are
you halftime barry gonzalez at half the
time
did i hear that right that you're still
actually conducting classes while
like being ceo is that true yeah
that's correct i love that do you feel
like you know i often talk about
vayner x's great competitive advantage
is that i'm a practitioner
of the content thus my strategies and
all this
and the other thing are able to become
real tangible and we're faster
you feel the fact that you're still in
the trenches conducting
those classes gives you a huge advantage
to operate
and see what's going on 100 i mean i
have the
4d experience right as a client always
taking classes
as an instructor being in the red room
oftentimes
with clients who have no idea that i'm
the global ceo
which is amazing because then i really
get to see all of our initiatives
yeah exactly taking place what's working
what's not why
rather than living in my glass tower and
relying upon you know the feedback of
people
around me and you know
also as someone who's you know managing
the business when i'm in studios i'm
behind the desk and i'm answering phones
and continuing to have those touch
points and then obviously as ceo
joey what uh when you hear the premise
of you know
customers to fans i feel like your
category
of the world health and wellness
exercise
physical fitness lends itself to that
ability
and and i know many people who've been
obsessed with this
this brand and truly feel like fandom
more than just like a good customer how
are you thinking about extending that
the brand's a little more mature now
it's in a different life so
i love trying to get into the inside of
that like how are you thinking about
that
yeah so i'll start off by saying uh
obviously i was a fan of the brand and i
have a distinct advantage of
having experienced that customer journey
of first-timer what am i getting into
here to obsessed
evangelists right so over the first 15
years of my tenure
i was really highly focused on
recognizing and maintaining
the two things that led to my own
conversion which number one was the
product
you know the best workout really in the
world that i have ever that i had ever
done
uh efficient results driven
uh and then number two this incredible
feeling that i had of being a part of a
community or as
we call it embarrass a family um but
then
potentially more importantly i've
actually
focused on our areas of opportunity so
where could the brand go from here
right and that's easy to see as well
when you're a client so
improve the client experience right
premiumize the brand when i joined as a
client there were
there was one toilet in the studio that
everybody had to share
and today you know we have beautiful
locker rooms and showers and amenities
with orbe hair care product and dyson
hair dryer
i apologize uh vader team anybody in the
facebook page there's a garyvee
dot gift spam bot right now trying to
trick people into
clicking the profile and winning money
so hey that is
spam b can we stop i'm sorry joey go
ahead no no problem
uh and then lastly you know we've been
expanding
our community obviously through growth
and we're now across 14 countries around
the world so what used to be this sort
of
connection to a very small close-knit
west hollywood community has become this
sort of gateway to uh to the world to a
global community of of clients that have
a lot in common with you
i'd say please go ahead one of your i
think questions to a lot of people today
has been like how does that translate
into 2021
and i think lastly but most importantly
we've become incredibly
values focused very socially responsible
organization
with our mission and our vision at the
forefront
always and i think that this is the
piece
the one piece that's helped us the most
over the past year given how
unstable things have been for everybody
on planet earth
agreed what what do you have a sense of
what
triggered you into fandom like really
triggered you to that next place with
with the brand yeah i think it was the
combination
of it was that journey of being really
intimidated by the brand
um then having the actual experience of
showing up
and not only enjoying it but feeling
embraced
by you know the front desk feeling taken
care of by the person next to me on the
treadmill
so those are all the sort of elements of
the experience that we've tried to
preserve and actually
enhance i love that um what about
the ability to use digital for a
business like this
to advance people from you know a
user customer occasionalist to that
fandom is that something that you spend
a lot of time thinking about
think about your role think about that
business i would be
my intuition and i'm guessing but i'm
asking
is that must be a top of mind thought
you're talking about through paid social
or are you talking about through our
digital product
you know what's funny like um let's talk
about the acquisition and awareness
marketing side um
but i'll be honest with you i would also
be thrilled if you took it there i'm
curious about
when you have something that is physical
you know
whether it's the app whether it's an
alexa skill whether it's
virtual just curious about the
digitalization
layer of turning people from customers
to fans
so i'd say one of the silver linings of
the pandemic for us like so many or the
organizations
uh was that we had the opportunity and
the time
to rethink of ways in which we could
invest
and engage with our community which
resulted in a lot of different
innovations like
take for example our berries and home
product
our berries outdoors product of which we
have several modalities
our berries open gym product right we
just continue to sit back
and innovate which is one of our core
values and the berries at home was our
first
experiment with anything digital and it
undoubtedly highlighted
a whole segment of the population who
couldn't
get to a physical studio but was
seeking that at-home workout with the
personalized attention from instructors
in an intimate setting
and one of the differentiators of
berries and most of the digital
experiences and platforms out there
is that it's a many-to-many experience
so not only is the cam on me while i
teach
the cam is on you while you take and so
i'm not just performing on a stage i'm
actually saying like gary flatten your
back soften your knees that's not a
correct deadlift blah blah you know and
i'm engaging with everybody in class and
there's like a capacity on who can take
class
so it's a much more hands-on premium
experience
um and we've seen you know coming out of
covid
i think we can say that now we are
officially you know beginning to come
out of kovit
how does that feel by the way like the
last two three weeks i'm like wait a
minute
is that light is that lights it's like
it's just like more and more good news
keeps coming so i'm just gonna you know
keep my fingers crossed but we've seen
various segments sort of
um come out and one is like the group
the population of people that has
raced back to the red rooms and said
goodbye the digital experience
the second which i think will be the
majority are those that are having the
omnichannel experience right they are
racing back to the red room
but two or three days a week they're
joining us on our at home product
and third which i think is like the most
exciting
is that we've created this segment
this population of people who become
members that
have never and may never live close to a
berry studio
but they're committed to being a part of
this global community exclusively in
this digital way
joey sometimes barry thank you for being
on the show bro
happy new year thank you have a great
one
last up we welcome jill crest head of
growth marketing
at papel and venmo where she increases
consumer acquisition
and engagement prior to joining paypal
jill was cmo of national geographic and
a top leader at mastercard
fun fact jill has celebrated an annual
pilgrimage to rio
until the pandemic and she lives by her
motto
start by starting welcome jill
jill how are you i'm great gary thanks
for having me how are you
i'm well uh first i like look in your
background i'm like oh she should
nft those paintings they're so awesome i
love that
um it's all about the nft that's right
oh god it's everywhere uh
jill um let's just go first into the
question you know obviously
paypal and venmo brand how are you
thinking about or when
when a question like this is posed to
you how are you growing your customers
into fans in 2021 any emerging
technologies
any any overall strategies
how do you how do you approach that at
your level
yeah so we've got these two amazing
platforms paypal which is global
370 million users around the world and
then venmo at nearly 70 million users
and you know the activity that has
played out on these
platforms over the last year since we've
been in the pandemic
has been a huge inspiration for how we
build community because we start to
see all this use and it's really looking
at how we're enabling what matters to
people right you know the way that they
stayed connected
to um friends they cared about people
they cared about
causes they cared about the giving that
took place on the platform
and so it was through all of these use
cases
that we started to see ways in for
paypal to bridge the gap between
digital commerce and physical commerce
and launching things like
qr code across both paypal and venmo
um on venmo we've seen that you know
you know venmo it's all about the emojis
right so you know we started to see
all these really great trends in march
of last year we saw the mask
emoji increase by 375
right so you see how relevant and
contextual the interaction is on that
platform
and then we saw people taking care of
each other right like sending money to
their baristas or
frontline workers and we saw just more
commerce
playing out and so we have accelerated
activity to
allow users to do more with venmo so
you're gonna see venmo commerce
um enabling small merchant small
businesses on the platforms
it's right so it's like just extending
you know the fun inclusive nature of
venmo
into the commerce space bringing large
enterprises like
cvs on board to accept paypal and
venmo's qr code
um so it's really understanding like
what is the job that these platforms are
doing for our users
how can we do more of it and then how do
we celebrate why
it matters to the user and kind of step
back from our role
and celebrate our role as an enabler
like it's not about paypal it's not
about venmo it's about how you use it
how do you how do you get people to
consume that celebration because
to your point i see a lot of companies
evolved and have gotten to that
thoughtful place of like look we're a
tool
and what's far more interesting than the
story of like how our pipes work
is the empowerment of
right um when you think about telling
those stories
in a 2021 way
what do you think about a the creative
format
provided and needed to get people to
actually give a crap
because i think that's a huge issue of
like customers to fans is
the creative variable and then even to
that point
the distributions you know you're a very
advanced company
how do you think about your media mix of
like outdoor
sponsorship television ott social
digital
thoughts on that because we haven't
touched on that a lot and i'm admiring
of your career and i'm curious of your
perspective on that
yeah all of that plus in a really
powerful way across our platforms
our own access and how does that can how
does that experience come across to the
user so
we've taken a ton of inspiration from
the use cases that have played out so in
our content over the last year
you've seen us really highlighting how
how paypal
and venmo had served our users so we did
our kind of first
ever hero anthem during covid and
it was a nod to all the jobs that the
platform was doing so
during coven we started to see a lot of
emojis playing out around like bread
right and we started to see notes like
bread for bread and we look at that and
say like what's happening here and it
was actually kind of this craze
around sourdough starters and people
paying each other for bread so
you know we worked that into our hero
film of you know um
how communities were coming together to
just like get food on the table and
uh you know we saw incredible rise of um
home care personal care goods you know
hair
dye uh dog grooming shears and so we
just started to like
focus in on all those fun unique ways
that um consumers are using the platform
and we created all sorts of content
right like we
we had you know a lot of uh mid funnel
content that just showed those fun
ways and then we explained mid funnel
jill for all the non-marketing nerds
yeah so a lot of digital you know a lot
of digital content that you'd see
across like public publisher platforms
lots of focus on social
um and using that to drive um you know
demand and consideration for our
products
and please yeah so i mean i guess to
just go back to your question gary i
mean we were
um you know we were at the you know some
for the first time we found ourselves in
out of home to drive awareness around
our in-store solutions like that was a
big pivot right as consumers were not
wanting to touch
money we we moved into the physical
acceptance space with qr codes
and so we entered back into out of home
in big
urban markets where you know you have
proximity
were you concerned about people staying
indoors during that time of that media
spend
i'm sure that ran through your mind
right like you buying a billboard during
covid you just have to assume
their pricing structure obviously i'm
sure you've negotiated but like
you know there was obviously a lot more
people indoors on at
unprecedented levels yeah absolutely um
and you know we had a we actually did
really well with our out of home
um impact so we did it in a way where we
were able to isolate
we did a bunch of geo testing to see
like what was the impact of out of home
on top of lots of digital lots of social
and all the performance paypal is a
performance
um marketing engine as you can imagine
i'm sure yeah
right so it was a good op brand offset
right
was and we saw awareness and
consideration and
uh you know really increase in those
markets where we had it so
you know consumers were you know we were
strategic in where we placed it yeah
joe before we let you go and wrap up the
show um
you as a customer which brand has been
able to penetrate you
jill the human not the marketer and turn
you from
a user or customer until until
into excuse me an advocate that became
fan-like
across paypal and venmo two brands that
i looked after oh okay no no
you living your life yeah you know
nike mcdonald's cedars i'm just putting
has a brand caught you in the last two
or three years and really surprised and
delighted you or
made you a fan you know what so i i have
been
an avid member of the soul cycle
community and i loved that
that physical experience um my
my affection has uh wavered towards
peloton and it's been an interesting
experience to see yeah to see like how
that um that
digital lead brand and the way that they
were able to really
foster community versus soul seg which
was born out of community but
was very much around that physical
experience and
god love them they're trying really hard
to make it work as they
you know get their digital um experience
up and running but you know it's the
first like you know we all have to work
out right
um i love to have my glass of wine i
have to offset it somehow
and so soulcycle was the thing that got
me to love working out right they do it
five six days a week i still do i've got
one in the basement
um but you know i i've had a peloton as
well and i think their
their their community experience is
something that we can all take a page
from
jill i really appreciate having you on i
hope you have a great great great
uh spring uh and thanks for sharing your
insights
thanks for having me take care
that's it andrea thanks gary and thanks
everybody for joining us
next show april 15th from 12 to 2
will be focused on what's the future of
music audio
and sonic in 2021 we've got a pretty
awesome lineup
the one and only kara swisher won
republic's ryan tedder
and clubhouse's newest joiner fadia in
addition to a long list of really
fantastic brands so please
um continue to follow us on hashtag
marketingforthenow
and check out our past recordings and
info on marketing for the now on
vaynerx.com
we hope to hear from you soon thanks for
having me everybody make sure you
register as you can see on the scroll
down here
the next uh you do not want to miss the
audio uh
episode i think for a lot of you that
i'm seeing in the comments it will be an
impactful one mftn
they make sure you absolutely sign up
we'll see you next time thanks for being
on hit me up on twitter with your
thoughts on today's show
see ya